[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Бессарабія, Шагани
Маяк Шаган]
Усе тут неторкнуте,
неторкнуте ніким і нічим.
Приїжджаю сюди і, вірите, відчуття таке, атмосфера,
[Віктор Сакара
Маячник]
як у фільмі «Сеньйор Робінзон».
Отут коли прокидаєшся, можна
почути різноманіття таких птиць:
там гуска сіла, тут пелікан пливе.
Місця красиві, дуже хороші,
лише дайте їм дихання...
От, будь ласка: прісний лиман впадає в солоний.
Солоний впадає, аж туди далі, до Одеси.
Це коса Чорного моря.
[говорить нерозбірливо]
І отак я тут уже 16 років.
Забезпечую безпеку судноплавству.
Я сам навіть не думав, що буду маячником.
Хоч мій дід — теж маячник.
Мій дід також був маячником.
Саме цього маяка. Маяк Шагани.
Він тут стояв ще з румунського періоду.
Він маячив, що тут є небезпечна ділянка
Зміїної скелі.
Румунська Зміїна скеля.
Треба було людину на цей пост, саме фахівця.
Я був зв'язкіцем.
Показав, що можу у всіх їхніх питаннях.
Ну й пройшов по конкурсу.
Ну і тепер можу...
Я сам і технік, і механік,
все це обслуговую і забезпечую
безперебійну роботу маяка.
Море тут прибуває так,
що це все заливає водою.
І ця хвиля йде так через бархани,
і тут — бух! — розбивається.
Це кожен день, ось тут, бачите,
я переходжу через цей канал, у воді.
Штани рибальські — що туди, що назад,
що літо, що зима.
Я повинен виїхати, повинен подивитися.
Кожного дня потрібно запустити маяк.
Він має працювати.
У мене тут прапор висить,
як заведено, України.
Я казав і казать буду:
всім нашим, навіть в нашім селищі:
«Якщо вам щось не подобається —
300 гривень, залізничний вокзал.
Магадан великий. Їдьте!».
Їдьте!
Не мутіть воду! Їдьте!
Не подобається тут — я тобі ще доплачу.
Куплю квиток — лиш їдь!
Їдь, Магадан освоюй. Все.
Та не мути тут воду!
Ось так. І в нас багато таких є людей.
Я сам українець і буду українцем завжди.
І діти мої будуть українцями завжди.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператор
Павло Пашко, Марія Теребус]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Марія Теребус]
[Музика
Sleeping bear]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]